Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
This is Rob and in today's installment of our beyond Omega level series,
where we break down the origin and powers of the most powerful characters in
comics. We are focusing on one of DC comics, most powerful heroes,
firestorm.
So firestorm was created by Jerry Conway and Al Milgrom at first appeared in his
own self-contained series in 1978.
Now Firestorm's origin is unique in that it involves not just one individual,
but two. The first is high school student, Ronnie Raymond,
who joins an activist group,
opposed to the development of nuclear technology and an effort to seem
intelligent and conscientious in order to impress a girl, no one,
the group decides to blow up a nuclear power plant. Ronnie tries to intervene,
but the group incapacitates him and tied him up so that he would die in the
explosion. Now they also attacked and rendered unconscious the plants,
the designer, Nobel prize, winning scientists, Martin Stein.
And so the explosion in the nuclear reactor created a blast of atomic energy
that did not actually kill Ronnie and Dr. Stein,
but instead fuse them into one incredibly powerful entity.
Although the two would be able to split back into their respective bodies now
because Ronnie,
Raymond was conscious during the explosion and Martin Stein was not,
Ronnie was in full control of the newly created body,
but he could mentally communicate with Martin,
which would be important because his expertise provided a much better
understanding of their powers than Ronnie would have had on his own.
There was a problem. However,
as Dr. Martin could not remember anything from the time when he and Ronnie
fused. And so every time Ronnie became firestorm,
Martin believed himself to black out. When in reality,
his mind was present within the mind of Ronnie Raymond.
Eventually Rodney revealed to Martin, what was actually going on in firestorm.
We begin operating as a superhero based in New York,
although Ronnie was still in high school during that time. Now,
once Ronnie graduated,
he attended a university in Pittsburgh where Martin would also begin teaching
and they tried to find a way to sever the bond between the two of them. Now,
there were several different iterations of the firestorm character following the
original version, for example,
what an atomic bomb was dropped on firestorm and his Soviet counterpart poser
whose real name was Mikhail.
Arcaden the two of them merged into a new firestorm. However, in this state,
firestorm was controlled by the mind of Martin Stein,
who at this point was a music.
Then there was a period where firestorm was actually revealed to be a fire
elemental. So basically the living embodiment of fire and in this form,
he was comprised of Ronnie Raymond Mikael Arcaden and a Russian clone of
firestorm, but not long after that,
Martin Stein learns that he supposed to be Earth's fire elemental.
So he takes over complete control of firestorm and Ronnie and Mikael were deep
powered and went back to their regular lives.
Now firestorm would then disappear into a void of space and basically
disappeared from comics for a pretty lengthy amount of time. Ronnie,
Raymond would later get cancer and see his powers restored when he began taking
chemotherapy, which doesn't really make any sense,
but this was short-lived as well because Ronnie would basically die during
identity crisis. Now in 2004,
a new firestorm would be introduced in the form of Jason Rush,
a teenager from Detroit who was possessed by the firestorm entity,
which needed a new house. Now that Ronnie was dead. And so over the years,
Jason would share firestorm duties with both Martin Stein and Ronnie Raymond.
And once the new 52 rebooted DC's continuity, Ronnie and Jason,
who were classmates became firestorm after they were exposed to the God,
particle a creation of their teacher, Dr. Martins stunt, as a, like I said,
there've been a lot of different incarnations of the characters,
some of which makes sense. And some of which don't,
and I don't really plan to spend so much time talking about them all,
but they are all pretty powerful.
So let's just get into what Firestorm's powers are since that's really what you
guys care about. So one of Firestorm's most notable abilities is matter.
Manipulation at a molecular level,
firestorm can change the atomic makeup of any substance to change its shape or
molecular composition to anything he can imagine.
This is why the role of Martin Stein is so important as his expertise and
physics allows him to guide Ronnie in ways to rearrange molecules,
to achieve his desired results.
That was a matter manipulation ability allows firestorm to perform on nearly
endless variety of feeds,
such as creating a alleged shield out of the molecules in the air or conjuring a
cage made of kryptonite seemingly out of nothing.
There are countless other examples of firestorm using this ability because his
ability to transmute molecules is limited only by his imagination.
And so he can basically manipulate molecules to change any object, any,
any other object or even conjure any object of his choosing out of thin air
disability allows firestorm the power to change his shape at will and regenerate
any of his tissue that's damaged.
He can also alter his density to become intangible and phase through solid
objects, firestorm, possesses, superhuman, strength, durability, and stamina.
Having gone toe-to-toe with the new gods,
which are some of the strongest characters in DC comics firestorms also been
able to take hits from captain Adam,
who I have a beyond Omega level video on if you guys want to go check it out,
but who's also an incredibly powerful character and was also able to harm
captain Adam with his own punches. Now, in addition to his incredible strength,
firestorm is able to fly faster than the speed of sound.
Not only can firestorm transmute matter, he can manipulate energy as well.
He's able to absorb massive quantities of energy and can then use that energy to
produce nuclear explosions that have enormous destructive capability.
Firestorms blast have harmed new gods Orion and Calabash as well as black
Adam Noah Martin Stein was in sole possession of firestorm.
As the fire elemental,
he was able to produce enough energy to close off a black hole.
On another occasion,
he was able to close a rift in the multi-verse created by Alexander Luther.
The amount of energy firestorm could harness seems to have no upper limit.
And Martin Stein has theorized that in fact,
no limits exist and firestorm contains all the energy that was created by the
big bang and could therefore have the potential to destroy everything in
existence, except for himself. If he exploded.
Morton also suggests that the explosion of firestorm could trigger another big
bang, creating an entirely new universe. Jesus.
Now these are only a few of firestorms, more impressive feats,
but it's nowhere near an exhaustive list of everything he's done.
But just from these examples,
we know that firestorm is well beyond Omega level.
Anyone who can manipulate matter can pretty much do anything they want and
firestorm has exhibited vast matter manipulation abilities. In addition to that,
the fact that he could produce enough energy to bring about the destruction of
the universe makes firestorm a no brainer on the list of most powerful
characters in comics.
Because a lot of people's only exposure to firestorm is through the CW shows.
I think that many are not aware of just how insanely powerful he is.
If you follow his powers to the logical conclusion, there's very little,
the firestorm would not be able to do what would that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you guys are new here to come and explain the mission,
you guys are the sub button to become part of the Rob port.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a light.
Now we'll catch you all up.
Bruce.
[inaudible].